good news after a staggered release date
and an 11th hour delay titanfall has
finally arrived
on the Xbox 360 more good news it's
totally titanfall all the high-flying
parkour the fierce multi-level
firefights and the brutal Titan battles
are intact all the modes maps and
loadout elements are here as well when I
play titanfall on the Xbox 360 I get the
same feature list and more importantly
the same thrills that I do while playing
on the Xbox one and the PC I do not
however get the same visuals titanfall
looks notably worse on the Xbox 360 when
compared to the Xbox one and PC versions
the resolution is softer the textures
are blurrier and often slower to load
and the framerate stutters more often
soldiers are harder to see at a distance
a fact that the developers seem to have
compensated for by making the lights on
far-off enemies glow slightly brighter
than those on closer foes it does the
trick
but if you put titanfall 360 next to
titanfall PC or Xbox one you're going to
notice the visual disparity but if you
compare it to other games on the
platform you won't see as big of a gap
titanfall isn't really a beautiful game
on any platform but the maps have some
nice visual touches that you can
appreciate regardless of what system
you're using and most importantly
titanfall on the 360 gives you all the
visual information you need to succeed
and then some
the fast fluid action demands that the
visuals keep up and with relatively
minor exceptions they do they totally do
if you want to know more about titanfall
be sure to watch or read GameSpot's full
review I wrote it and all of it applies
to the Xbox 360 version of the game if
you have the choice played on Xbox one
or PC but regardless of how you
titanfall you're gonna have a blast
[Music]